hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
april 25th
2022
2222 what's going on everybody how are
you
oh billy hey fever
i got a little bit of a cold here
oh billy too much fun
oh billy [ __ ] uh
not sitting in the sun so i'm in uh
i'm in where the hell am i ah [ __ ] i
hope this isn't [ __ ] with my
recording incoming call here
i am in um
columbus ohio
trying to [ __ ] drink plenty of fluids
here to get rid of my cold and i'm
watching the new orleans breakers
versus the tampa bay bandits
some usfl action
and i got to be honest with you i'm
still heartbroken all these years later
40 years later that the boston breakers
left
boston to go down to new orleans they
never appreciated them look at that all
the way down to the four yard line 37
seconds to go in the first quarter
i'm just saying this just in case
somebody's actually taping this game
there's literally three people in the
[ __ ] crowd
this is decent football though i don't
know what the problem is why people i
guess because the nba playoffs are
happening
i might have to get a new orleans break
to the end zone back shoulder touchdown
oh he dropped it oh god i was like the
yankees guys it is far it is deep that
ball is caught what happened
it wasn't even the back shoulder oh we
tried to one-hand it there
an nfl guy would have done that
i like watching these usfl games because
everybody in this league does not want
to be in this league they're all right
down to the announcers everybody's
hoping that someone from the nfl is
watching this [ __ ] touchdown breakers
um
my god there is literally
oh my god there cannot be more than
[ __ ] 200 people at that game
that would be amazing you got to go to
these games guys if there's a [ __ ]
usfl game near you you got to go
these are all [ __ ] division one
players for the most part i would think
they just didn't get drafted or whatever
this is still like watching a college
all-star game not maybe not the top tier
one
you get to watch it
with 200 other people
they're like come on
um
who's the uh the redheaded fellow there
used to coach the dallas cowboys he's up
in the booth i was watching him i'm like
this guy's doing a good job kind of a
funny way of holding the mic a little
bit but other than that i think it's all
right you know he's kind of holding the
uh the mic like it's a wine glass
and i'm like well he was in dallas for a
while you know dallas
that's the beverly hills of uh
of texas is a two-point conversion for
you
what in the [ __ ] just happened they went
up six to nothing and then they threw
another one am i watching highlights
here
what just happened there now all of a
sudden
wow what a great catch all of a sudden
now they're up 14 to nothing is there a
two-point conversion you can go for
another touchdown
oh these wacky other leagues that can't
be right um maybe it was already six
nothing hey bill maybe 99 of people
aren't watching the game right now you
should shut the [ __ ] up all right well
you just missed a hell of a catch
that you you could have lit this you
could literally take everyone who's
going to your wedding
okay and go to a usfl game there'd be
more people at it than this this is
[ __ ] amazing
um
anyway and i want to give a shout out
to a new york yankee fan i know you new
york yankee fans are taking a little bit
of [ __ ] because a couple of knuckleheads
out there in [ __ ] right field i saw
this great video
i posted it on my instagram stories for
all you kids out there
there was a new york yankee fan
at the game he looked like he was by
himself he had a beer he had on his
yankees jacket
[Music]
and he had a hot dog and he was dunking
the hot dog into the beer and then
eating it like
like a cop would dunk a donut into a
coffee why not a fireman i don't know
because that's the stereotype
and i just saw that i was like yeah
that's what you used to see at games
you used to just see like all of these
like these sports fans doing weird [ __ ]
like that i remember the first time i
went to wrigley field
early 80s when leon durham was there the
great bill buckner still love that guy
rest in peace bill buckner um
i remember the guys behind us were
drinking beers and this guy kept pouring
salt a little bit of salt into his beer
my dad told me was to take the head down
or something i don't know what the [ __ ]
it was i've never seen anybody do that
there was all these and then all it was
was just hot dogs peanuts
and [ __ ] booze that was it
great defensive player in the backfield
um
is that von miller's brother
some guy named miller
um
yeah just to see that [ __ ] like i i
gotta be honest with you i really
you know i was talking to a buddy of
mine who was saying like you know if i
had the money
if i had the time if i had the power and
i had the woman
i would buy the pittsburgh pirates
i'd take him away from that awful
ownership who really should be forced to
sell
and um
i would take over that stadium and not
only would i try to make the team
competitive i would bring it back
where you're not trying to attract
people who aren't really even that into
sports
you know
oh now i'm watching a commercial in the
rocks in it
for some movie this looks like a good
movie you know i saw oh young rock i
gotta watch that you know i saw this
[ __ ] video of him and he was talking
to these young kids he's like going you
know i love you guys
i'm proud of you guys
but none of you [ __ ] is gonna
outwork me
none of you can hear me
none of you like
and it just bothered me that no one in
the crowd was like
i'll [ __ ] outwork you
nobody they just sat there and took it
none of you [ __ ] it's gonna
outwork me it was really amazing it was
like it was a motivational speech and
then he started giving him [ __ ]
all at the same time
um
but how are you gonna argue with the guy
the guy's like [ __ ] well into his 40s
and he's absolutely shredded
and you're sitting there in your 20s you
already got a [ __ ] potato skins pooch
hanging over your [ __ ] junk
you're like well you know maybe he's
right
uh thanks
i want to do that
i want to be that motivational speaker
that [ __ ] goes around and inspires
people
you know you it's like you do the duel
thing you inspire people while also
sorry subtly saying they're never going
to be as good as you
i'm going to do that i'm going to teach
a stand-up comedy class and do that
let me tell you something i love you
guys
you guys are all funny
and you all have a bright future ahead
of you but let me tell you something
right now
none of you [ __ ] is going to
lean on a mic stand the way i do
hear me
none of you
just be [ __ ] staring at him as i'm
leaning on the mic stand
um you will always open for me you
understand me um
just [ __ ] around i love the rock i
not only do i love the rock i watch
everything that he said
okay and i'm old school i can't say
totally old school if i was a really old
old-school rock fan i would have watched
him when he was with the hurricanes but
i actually i've been watching him since
the uh
when he was wrestling
and i would still say i mean
if anybody ever said
this is like sacrilegious he's the only
guy i ever saw
that could [ __ ] with ric flair
on the mic
and just as a comedian
what i loved was he didn't rest on his
catch phrases he was always adding new
stuff to what he was doing like this
there was just
there hasn't been a guy like that before
or since
how [ __ ] amazing that guy is i think
and i would say in the modern era which
i consider the late 90s because i'm an
old guy the modern era i've yet to see
somebody after him
all you young people if there's somebody
out there that you think is
is as good as the rock i want to see
that guy because that [ __ ] guy
you know
i remember at the beginning the super
bowl this year when he was like finally
the super bowl has come back
to los angeles
this female comedian i know texted me
and she goes did we really need that at
the beginning of the game and i was like
absolutely we [ __ ] absolutely did
it's one of my favorite intros to a
[ __ ] super bowl ever
what are we supposed to have
you know
one of those [ __ ] goddamn whining
rock bands now talk sing about their
emotions you know i blame the whole
seattle rock scene on like emo music on
the seattle scene they they just [ __ ]
they came in and they just [ __ ]
changed it
whining about their [ __ ] days they
couldn't just block their feelings
the way the hair metal bands did you
know
i'll tell you right now if you're not
watching this usfl game the portland
breakers
i mean the new orleans breakers are they
the portland bro i don't know where the
new orleans
the warling breakers are uh
they're putting on a clinic here on how
to beat the tampa bay [ __ ] uh
strip malls whatever they're called the
trampa bay bandits
um oh look at that is that a female
driver
somebody just won a race in a pink car
i'm guessing that's a female driver no
it's a guy
maybe he lives an alternative lifestyle
he's with a woman
there's a lot going on there you know
when you watch tv with the sound down i
mean a lot of different things start
happening look at the stars they put on
the ball in usfl
i like it you got to have you know when
you have a new league
you got to have a different [ __ ] they
don't have money for cups either look at
the quarterback's junk hanging to the
right
you've got to have
i mean like it was right in the middle
of the screen people
what do you want from me
um
anyway you got to have a different ball
like the uh the afl did the way the aba
did i think that that's that that right
there is is a good sign for investors
that you could possibly
be creating a league that will
eventually merge
i don't know there's probably too many
goddamn teams at this point i mean the
nfl has 32 franchises but god knows they
they're always looking to add
more
you know
like i'm wondering do you ever think the
nfl would ever get up to 40 teams
i mean who would thought that they would
ever add a game and play 17 games which
by the way i [ __ ] hate
i [ __ ] hate
17
because now i got to rethink my whole
you know when you try to predict
predict what do you think they're gonna
do this year go [ __ ] you know nine
and seven ten and six now you gotta be
like what do you think they're gonna do
this year nine and eight ten and seven
you gotta ask yourself
is ten and seven good enough to make the
playoffs this year
it's just weird they're weird numbers
not a fan
oh billy grouchy cakes doesn't like an
extra game of nfl footballs he sits here
watching spring football look at the
[ __ ] they got little stars on the
front of him when somebody throws a
spiral it looks cool
um all right i got i got to do a little
vanity thing here i'm not going to lie
to you
club soda kenny
sent me video
center field camera of me throwing out
the first pitch i've probably watched it
78 times today
[Laughter]
it still hasn't worn off
it's the coolest thing i think i ever
did
i still can't believe it
i talked about the picture mount right
it's i'm telling you it's it's [ __ ]
synthetic dirt it's not even it was like
illuminati level dirt it was the
cleanest dirt i've ever seen in my life
like if you fell down on it your clothes
would be cleaner somehow it was
incredible
you know bull durham they always talked
about how you know playing baseball like
every ball was when you get to the show
how all you played with was like the new
baseballs
jesus christ look at that [ __ ] coach
i don't know what he was looking at but
i don't i don't think he's ever gonna
figure out whatever the hell he was
trying to figure out
oh christ there's a sloppy play on third
and goal now we got to settle for a
field goal
um you know what's funny about this [ __ ]
is you know there's somebody out there
that has money
on this game what do you think how you
think of taking the
the br i don't i like tampa i like tampa
and the points
christ they didn't show up just like the
crowd um
anyway uh so i've been doing my tour
this week and uh i started off
in pittsburgh
which was absolutely incredible and they
blocked the [ __ ] field goal
god damn it
why do i i still love that i actually
have some sort of a like like loyalty
to the usfl breakers i do you know
that's the thing man
now who the [ __ ] had campbell the guy
went right in and blocked the goddamn
thing
the [ __ ] the field goal kicker looking
at
do you think it's going to bounce back
around
he's probably looking up to see if his
girlfriend left too
goddamn she left his league's going
under
um he's probably watching the replay
that's what he was doing um anyway so i
started off in pittsburgh then went to
nashville then up to cleveland and i'm
in columbus tonight i'm recording this
uh sunday afternoon and uh i want to
thank everybody that has come out to the
shows
it's been these those are as far as
shows that i've done
um
i've never done shows this big back to
back to back to back in my life the
amount of people coming out to see me
i'm not gonna lie to you is uh
i'm not glad you kind of overwhelming
you know and it wasn't until last night
where kind of like i was kind of
freaking out the first two nights
and i started like catastrophizing you
know i'm like what am i doing this is
too big
i don't want to do this this is [ __ ]
stupid like this is [ __ ] that you think
about before you go out
i'm just going like you know just
[ __ ] give me a 1200 seater i'll just
do my [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody just
[ __ ] leave me alone and then i
remember thinking back
to um
way back in the day when i first started
selling tickets
which was in 2005
and i remember the first gig i did
i had an hbo half hour came out and i
was covering for jim norton
on uh
opie uh and anthony's show right
so i had that going on and then i had
the half hour special came out and then
all of a sudden i went from
you know basically selling
hardly any tickets and people just kind
of going to the comedy club because
that's what you did like hey let's check
out
see see who's down there maybe the guy's
funny like that's kind of the crowd that
i had
to all of a sudden
i played rascals in new jersey and it
was the first time i met paul verzi
new jersey's own paul ferzi
um
and i went there and and the place was
packed and there was like this
excitement people wanted to see me
and i heard a few people yell my name
and i remember being in the green room
and i was freaking
the [ __ ] out
because it was this whole new level of
pressure where before the pressure was
can i convince these people
that i'm funny
and that's basically the pressure that
you deal with as a comedian from day one
as a comic the first time you do your
first open mic
you got to go out there and show the
people that you're funny because
obviously no one knows who you are and
it's also an open mic so they're
expecting you to suck
so that was my whole career from 1992
until 2005.
so
i was really comfortable with the crowd
sitting there thinking that
you know who the [ __ ] is this guy this
guy isn't funny i was that was my sort
of
you know comfort zone
and then uh
all of a sudden yeah
i had those two things happen in my
career and um
all of a sudden there was a comedy club
full of people that wanted to see me and
i felt
for the first time in my life the
pressure of expectation
where now it wasn't hey let's go down
there and see who you know see if this
guy who the [ __ ] this guy is or whatever
now it was we know who this person is
and we expect him
to be as funny as whatever the hell we
already saw
so i remember being down there and like
you know i was not comfortable with it
i wasn't comfortable with it that
weekend and i remember being at the
stress factory in new jersey i did a
couple of east coast gigs because
you know
opie and anthony was strong there
and i was also like you know when you
first do like a quick little half hour i
found like if you're from the northeast
you get like the
coasts and maybe you can sell some
tickets in like chicago you can kind of
go out to like cleveland or whatever but
a lot of that was because it was the
only markets too
so they were helping me sell a lot of
tickets and um
it took me like
like three weekends i think
before i was finally able to be like
okay
this is what you wanted
okay you're finally gonna make some
[ __ ] money jesus christ after [ __ ]
seven 13 years
finally gonna make some [ __ ] money
all right you have the act you're funny
you know what you're doing
just relax and go up there and have fun
but it took me three week weekends to
get that and i feel like on this tour
here i kind of did that again
where i was like in pittsburgh i was
like all right here we go pittsburgh
okay these [ __ ] these are this is you
know
big time sports fans
you know everybody comes to pittsburgh
everybody loves pittsburgh they got big
expectations and it's just like i've
gone there a zillion times and had
[ __ ] great sets
and i don't know why i just was like
getting in my head because now all of a
sudden i was performing
at a level of venue that i had never
performed for and then of course i got
out there the second i got out there
um it was immediately fine and i had a
great show and the fans were amazing
and um
i got to meet the great
hall of famer
franco harris
franco harris was at my show can you
believe i'm going to say that again
franco
harris
and his his lovely wife and his son doc
were all at my show
and um and it went great
and i got to meet
you know franco and his family after the
show
it was insane right so i was just like
that you know
i mean i can't even tell you what that
was like to meet that guy
i was just thinking of all the football
cards i had and being excited every time
you know i'd be opening the packs of
cards with my siblings or whatever and
like some of you like franco harris you
know when you would get his football
card
um
what also was cool
was uh
randy and
bill came bill crawford came down randy
bauman and bill crawford came down from
wdve
which they were the reasons i ever sold
even half a ticket
in pittsburgh because of those guys they
used to let me come in like on a tuesday
and just sitting on the show god i love
doing that it was [ __ ] awesome man
and um
they were also out at the show so at the
end of the show in the green room
i was talking to franco and somebody a
steeler fan showed me
the entire immaculate reception from a
50-yard line
camera
that has the whole thing and he without
a doubt
caught the ball before it
touched the ground
i mean you can still argue did it go off
an offensive player first who the [ __ ]
knows but like it always just seemed the
way nfl films cut it
that they were trying to do something
underhanded because they were showing
the play from that 50-yard line thing
and then they would always cut to the
close-up but what it really was
now that i've done a little directing
here what was is they they didn't they
were set up to watch where he where
terry threw the ball not where it was
going to ricochet
so they didn't have the shot so they
were probably in close
on where the ball was going to end up
and then it ricocheted to the right out
of frame so then they had to go to the
end zone shot
and all that they had
from that was sort of a a
three-quarter shot on franco so you
couldn't see the ground you could never
see if if he if it touched the turf or
not
and i got to watch it
with franco heiress how [ __ ] nuts is
that
um
anyway so then the next night i go down
to nashville
and um yeah i felt the same
like feeling again like what am i
this is too big what am i doing and blah
blah blah blah
and uh and then i went out there and it
went great again and then like
um
you know nashville was a mind [ __ ]
because i remember i went to a
predator's game their first or second
season
before they became like this big hockey
town
and i remember like
walking up to buy a ticket and i was
hearing you know nashville has all the
great live music and everything right
and i heard like this guy he was like
dressed like a cowboy in this little bar
and he was just singing
and he was singing like country music
and i'm walking past it to go buy a
ticket to go see nhl hockey like it
didn't even make sense and then i went
in there
by myself as i went to most of those
games back then
and uh
i remember uh
the puck went in the corner
and they just kicked a [ __ ] field
goal okay tampa bay did and i swear to
god if i could rewind on my hotel tv
there is literally 11 people in the end
zone
um
you guys got to get out and support this
league it's a good [ __ ] thing more
sports more sports less war that's my
hippie
mantra
um
anyway um
yeah so i went there and the puck went
in the corner this nashville predators
game i remember the lady behind me just
is
one of the predators
was going in to check the guys she she
you know was cheering on but didn't know
what the right hockey terminology
she literally she goes the [ __ ] goes in
the corner
the predator's going in and hit the
other guy and she just yells out she
goes squish him
[Music]
it's [ __ ] amazing and i remember
thinking like ah the nhl did it again
trying to bring the game down south
how many times are they gonna fail down
here how many times they're gonna give
atlanta a [ __ ] team and just realize
this ain't gonna work
and lo and behold
nashville becomes
this insane hockey town and ever since
then i feel like the nhl has made great
moves with where they put their teams
the vegas knights i mean the fans are
crazy there and i think the seattle
kraken are going to be [ __ ] huge too
so anyway last night i'm in cleveland
and uh
i'm waiting to go on and uh
vanessa fraction and joe bartnick are
opening for me and joe by the way is is
taping his show tonight his stand-up
special with all things comedy at what's
it called the den or something like that
in chicago all freckles is going to be
warming up the crowd
[ __ ] around trying out some new jokes
talking to the locals getting everybody
all lamped up
you know
for joe bartnick's first stand-up
special i got to tell you vanessa went
up
and just absolutely [ __ ] killed and
we've been playing a game i've been on
the road about you know you got to try
out new [ __ ] you got to try out one new
bit during your set
and she didn't chicken out and she did
her new bit and it went great
and then bartnik went up there and he's
totally in like
like
beyond mid-season form he's ready to
like tape a special he was up there like
just
you know one of the hardest i've ever
seen him kill just [ __ ] killed and
when he got off he was so excited about
how well he did he forgot his beer
okay and i'll tell you right now you
know joe barnes is excited when he
leaves you know
a third of a miller high life sitting up
on the stage
[Music]
so anyway
as they were up there killing
i was still having all of those feelings
of doubt and all of that [ __ ] and then
um
i don't know i thought about
that moment in my career when i was at
rascals and i was at
the stress factory i'm like no this is
what you do
when you get something bigger than what
you're used to is you turn into little
billy burr again who just wants to be
alone so no one can hurt him and blah
blah blah blah and pull your knees into
your chest
[ __ ] relax
go up there it's going to be fine these
people want to see you have a good time
and i went up there and like
had the best set i think of the three
nights
that i've done it and i was like okay
all right and now tonight i'm all
excited i'm in columbus
and i'm not feeling any of those
feelings other than that i'm just gonna
go up and have a great time
and [ __ ] around and try out some new
[ __ ] so um
[Music]
i don't know i was telling you that
story in case there's
younger comedians listening
because that's something that uh
you know what i just told you is not a
unique thing like that's what
performers i think go through
i don't know if you're wired like me i
should say some people are just i mean
they're ready to play an arena the first
the first night you meet him um the
first person that comes to mind with
that would be kevin hart
kevin hart when i met him he was ready
from day one
day one if you told him to go play an
arena he he would go out there with his
first five minutes with supreme
confidence
she was just
he was just wired that way so um
i was
as much as all that he's done i don't
think
i was you know i guess you're a little
surprised when somebody you work with is
all of a sudden starring in a movie but
i wasn't surprised that he could [ __ ]
handle it i mean
um
he just you know
i don't know one of those rare people
was just ready to go from the beginning
anyway let's talk about some other stuff
your boston celtics my boston celtics
are up three games to none
over the brooklyn nets and i gotta tell
you i was worried
about
um game three
because you know we went up two games to
none
and you know the cameras were on the
celtics fans not the smart ones who go
home
the drunk ones who hang out afterwards
and get in the camera like
and holding up four fingers like we're
gonna [ __ ] sweep these guys
and i'm thinking like what are they
doing these are the same people that are
heckling [ __ ] uh
kyrie irving what are you doing
you're just motivating these people just
[ __ ] go home don't say [ __ ]
you know some people [ __ ] watch
sports so they're if their team wins
that they can talk [ __ ] i don't know why
but that's
that is an unfortunate part of sports
fandom so anyway um i remember i was in
a cigar bar
afterward
like living my sports dream
okay i watched the end of the red sox
game even though we lost to the blue
jays we ended up taking two out of three
from us sons of [ __ ]
and um i was watching the end of the red
sox game with the celtics game on and
the red sox games ended and then they
were promoting
the bruins versus the penguins in
pittsburgh the next night that i was
gonna be in which we lost to them too
but um
i was like this is what i miss
i haven't experienced this since half my
life ago i left boston when i was 27 i'm
going to be 54. for half of my life i
have not lived i've lived in hostile
sports
uh behind hostile sports lines and i get
[ __ ] sick of it so anyway
um
as i was watching promote the bruins
game they cut to the after you know
celtics the post-game interviews and
they were cut into highlights of it and
i they show jason williams and he's
dressed like he just won a grammy
and then they cut to kevin durant and
he has on just
regular track suit
with this red knitted hat and he looked
like marvin gaye right before he went
into the studio and was gonna record
what's going on
so i was just sitting there going like
um we're looking like the miami
hurricanes right now when they got off
the plane wearing fatigues thinking the
whole [ __ ] was a foregone conclusion so
i was really nervous
that kevin durant was going to have a
big game
and that uh you know it was going to be
all of a sudden two games to one
and uh and then we'd be looking at the
next game of them being able to tie it
right up but [ __ ] celtics jesus
christ i only was able to watch
highlights
but my god jason williams jalen brown
marcus smart i mean
by the way congratulations one defensive
player of the year also hit a couple of
big threes down the road
um
or at least one that i saw and uh
you know we are on a collision course
i'll tell you with the milwaukee bucks
and everybody's going to see the match
up
that espn is too afraid to talk about
all right did he just [ __ ] catch that
that has got to be the greatest catch in
front of 18 [ __ ] people i've ever
seen in my life 316 to go
in the third quarter number nine for
your new orleans breakers goes up
one-handed catch
between two defenders
they kind of brought the other hand over
wow what a catch
people wanna they're not gonna go
because of the uniforms
that was a big time [ __ ] catch anyway
[Music]
there's a collision
a sports rivalry about ready to happen
and i don't know why espn is shying away
from
it but all the real nba fans know it's
coming
all right it is the rematch
of grayson allen and grant williams
a little backstory for you back when
grayson allen
was on the memphis grizzlies he was
playing a summer league game against the
boston celtics
and in the course of about 10 seconds he
committed two flagrant fouls against
grant williams
all grant did was just you know was it a
pic
screen whatever the [ __ ] you call it
from behind
grayson didn't like it
grayson's showing no grace
didn't like it whatsoever
and just sort of swung
at grant williams head
he gets a flagrant file you got to watch
it i should post it
because the announcers just rip them a
new one
and then uh
i don't know
like to where it is they come out of
that
celtics go back down with the ball
another screen grayson allen doesn't
like it grant williams goes up for a
[ __ ] layup and
he swung at his [ __ ] head is what it
looked like and he got himself ejected
now since then
i think grayson has stopped playing like
that i know today he had a big game with
the milwaukee bucks and he's been doing
great with the bucks and he scores all
kinds of points for him i think he's
changed his game all right but the
question is
when he sees grant williams will he
revert back
to who he was is that him is that who he
is
huh
will people on espn be screaming about
it
i'll tell you the show i want to see
stephen a smith
with mad dog russo
i mean all they need to add to that is
like [ __ ] bruce dickinson or rob
halford
and that will be the loudest show
in the history of forget about sports
anything
um a couple of screamers and that's
coming from me
that is coming from me
uh another thing when i was in cleveland
i got to swing by one of my favorite
comedy clubs in the country uh
hilarities
and i of course i was coming down with
the cold my favorite
club owner out there nick costas we got
to hang out so many
memories i had been in there in like 10
years and all of the memories
all of the friends that i met all of the
people that i've met all the times i
hung out all the sets all the comics all
of this stuff came flooding back
and i had nothing but um
just nothing but fond memories and i
swear to god if i didn't have kids
you know i would love to come through
there one time and just do like a
weekend you know when i and next time
i'm building an hour maybe do a monday
tuesday wednesday
um
but nick was class as always
unfortunately i had to leave a little
bit early because uh
i wasn't feeling well
um
but anyways i want to thank him and his
staff and everybody else and one of my
best friends in the elite in the league
in the in comedy nate craig was out
there
um
it was just a great time so anyway let's
with that let's do the uh let's do the
reads here for the week
oh would you look who it is
well well well would you look who it is
it's all zip
[Music]
zip recruiter everybody
um let's see here you know according to
the latest research 90 of employers
plan to make enhancing the employee
experience a top priority in 2022
after all a happy workplace is key to
attracting and keeping great employees
oh did they finally learn that treating
their employees like [ __ ] wasn't a good
idea and if you need to add more
employees to your team there's always
zip
regret
uh their matching technology helps you
find the right people for your roles
fast and right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
that's the new one that's the the 80s
hair metal devil reading of zip
recruiters
actually no i would have the pause it
would be like
biz
sorry
[Music]
uh uses its powerful technology pizzas
zip backwards uh technology to find and
match the right candidate up with your
job then it proactively presents these
candidates to you you can easily review
these recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
which encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip
is the number one rated hiring site in
you in the u.s based on g2 ratings zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four to five employers who post on
zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day that's fine that's right find the
right employers for your workspace with
ziprecruiter try it for free at this
exclusive web address
b-u-r-r zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
uh
would you look who it is
would you just look who it is it's all
movement
uh you know in a tiny apartment in
southern california two college dropouts
teamed up to create a watch company that
broke all the rules
didn't just break some of the rules it
broke
all
the rules with fair prices unexpected
colors i didn't see that coming and
clean original designs movement
pronounced movement it's mvmt
grew into one of the fastest growing
watch brands shipping to over 160
countries across the globe now movement
mvmt has expanded into blue light
glasses
minimalist jewelry and more styles
essentials that don't break the bank all
designed out of their california
headquarters i have those blue light
glasses for looking at computer screens
they're fantastic unless you go on the
road and you forget them like i did like
an idiot but they're amazing uh and you
all are now the first to know that
movement is having a huge sitewide sale
for mother's day get your mom some blue
glasses to go with their new watch their
prices are slashed up to 40 percent off
from april 25th to uh 21st to may 6th to
make sure you can get perfect the
perfect gift for mom from beautiful
watches to fine 18-karat jewelry
their platinum blue light glasses will
not only make you look great but filter
ninety percent off of the most intense
blue rays from your digital screen so
you can scroll comfortably
um the perfect gifts for family and
friends shop up to forty percent off for
mother's day and save big on the perfect
gift for mom join the movement by going
to mvmt that's michael victor michael
tango dot com slash burn now and enjoy
up to 40 off again that's mvmt.com
all right
well hang on a second
and we're back sorry
old sneezy here had to blow his [ __ ]
nose um
all right so here we go
all right the first letter from the fans
here yankee fans the iki fans are trash
now come on they had one incident it's
people in the bleachers everybody's fans
that are in the bleachers are a bunch of
[ __ ] animals all right hey bill i
don't even really hate the yankees
because i'm a pirate fan
yeah you also [ __ ] you guys beat him
in like 1960 or 61 right bill mazurowski
uh but they're just the all-time
classless fans
of all time
uh i'm sure you saw them trashing their
own field well they weren't trashing
their own field they were throwing [ __ ]
at people from the other team i'm from
outside of pittsburgh and there's a lot
of [ __ ] fans around here but they're
not entitled morons and that's a key
difference find a worse fan base in
baseball you can't oh come on people
have done way worse than that and so of
yankee fans in the late 70s somebody
threw a [ __ ] knife
from the upper deck
and it grazed the forearm or
somebody on the other team when they
were congratulating each other
for winning um
and back then everybody didn't have a
cell phone camera so the person didn't
get caught i wonder what that person
went on to do
you know just in a fit of anger they
threw it and then as it was going it's
like oh [ __ ] is that gonna hit somebody
gotta go gotta go
um yeah it was definitely unfortunate
what they did it was great to see you
know aaron judge and those guys go out
there and tell everybody to stop acting
like [ __ ] idiots but like
you know no yankee fans
there's some loud morons they sit out in
right field
and do all that stupid stuff
that's that part is stupid but if you
mean like you know a yankee fan that
knows the game
um they they
they're great i don't have a problem
with them
i really don't like i like listening to
like my big thing is if a yankee fan can
talk about the yankees in the 80s then
i'll listen to them you know or now talk
about them over there like the last 10
years
um
you know i've met some you know every
fan base has their good fans and they're
they're bad fans all right so i mean i'm
not gonna sit here as a boston fan and
start talking about behavior
considering some of the [ __ ] that we've
done uh it was an unfortunate incident
and you shouldn't [ __ ]
paint everybody
you know and i think a lot of the [ __ ]
that they're gonna get is because they
have all that money in 27 championships
but having said that
those people out in right field they're
they're kind of they're [ __ ] nerds i
always thought they were just nerds
with their chants and all of that stuff
it was really uh
sort of rocky horror pictures it was
very broadway musical i thought what
they would like the sports version of it
anyway
survival kicks in dear billy bloodbath
i've been thinking a lot lately about
how much better we perform when our life
depends on it everything from a mother's
adrenaline allowing her to lift heavy
shift
that's funny you said light
allowing her
to life heavy [ __ ]
and i was trying to fix what you wrote
and i took the f out of that and put it
on the other thing shift
to lift heavy [ __ ] to save her kid
to when soldiers or emergency workers
take their skills to the next level in
the heat of combat
yeah you get like that you get that
tunnel vision um
more like when i went out to throw out
that first pitch you know i'm kidding
but not really uh which leads to my
question if you had to fly a helicopter
through a canyon at high speeds and
significant turns would you be able to
we're not talking heavy rocket fire but
let's say someone's on your tail and
there's some
ground to air artillery no time to think
just time to act
talk to me what do you think
well i mean i wouldn't have a choice i
would have to i'm not saying that i
wouldn't [ __ ] up but um
no i think i could do it
absolutely i mean i couldn't do it in
the helicopter that i fly
i would fly it at the highest speed it
could fly
uh
no i think i could do it i could [ __ ]
haul ass might think i'd be trying to
look around every corner
in case there was wires or all of a
sudden you know if i was flying into one
of those dead-end canyons
so then what you have to do is uh what's
known as a quick stop and a helicopter
something you cannot do in an airplane
and that's why flying that low
in unfamiliar canyons is so much more
dangerous in a plane
than it is in a helicopter with a
helicopter you got to obviously look out
for wires
um
i mean i guess you do when you're
playing too but like if i was to
suddenly
make a turn and i saw the canyon was a
dead end
i could just do a quick stop
where a airplane
has to you know do like a u-turn so i
know when like when they're in an
unfamiliar area and they're flying low
like i watched this
horrible video of these people that died
they
landed in aspen
they were on their way across country
to refuel and all of that and it was a
hot day so density altitude was a lot
higher meaning the air
was a lot thinner than it usually is at
that altitude
causing you to not um
get the normal performance that you
would at that your your aircraft is
performing
at that altitude like it's at a much
higher altitude which causes you to have
to you know
be concerned about the weight
and all of that stuff that you have and
versus the distance you have to climb
out of there and these guys were
unfamiliar and they went down
a canyon
that they were unfamiliar with and they
couldn't get the altitude they needed
and i learned by watching that
um
they just showed something on carlton
fisk he didn't pass away did he why
would that be showing that here
um
they were showing uh
they were talking about how as a pilot
the safe way to fly
something like that if you're not
familiar is you you fly to one side of
the canyon
or the valley or whatever you're on one
side so if you do have to bank around
you don't have to
eat up
any more distance by getting to one side
of it so you can make the turn you can
immediately just enter the turn
and these guys didn't do that and then
they tried to do it and they just went
into the [ __ ] trees it's it's it's
horrible hang on a second please tell me
colton fist didn't [ __ ] pass away
please tell me that's just it's his
birthday or something
girl
they just for some reason just showed
him in the middle of a usfl football
game
ah
okay he's still alive
all right good jesus christ sorry i
didn't mean to scare you guys too i'm
watching a [ __ ] usfl game
and all of a sudden they were showing
him on the red sox and the white sox and
saying how many years he played and all
of that right
he's okay
wikipedia he's still alive all right
pudge
the great pudge fisk
um all right now that i scared the [ __ ]
out of you let's uh
[Music]
so anyways going back to that what do i
think would i be able to do it um
i would absolutely be able to fly way
beyond anything i've ever done
on my own skill level would i be able to
shake the pilot behind me probably not
because i think everybody is pretty much
a better pilot
and has more hours than me you know i
only have like 300 something although i
should be over 400 but i'm not allowed
to fly until i get the first edit of
this movie done so
um
that's where i'm at all right made in
america
oh this is my favorite thing by the way
i'm getting my mother-in-law one of
those u-turn turntables
uh that's made in america in
massachusetts uh made in america amps
hey guys headstrong
is a one-man operation has been hand
building two guitar amps for 19 years in
the us andrew themeless are you
listening
just like they were done in the 1950s
with no circuit boards or integrated
circuit chips
it's called headstrong
come on all you dad rockers out there
we're making a decent living because you
don't play in a band you know you're
going to get one of these
all hand wired using cloth covered wire
handmade vintage spec transformers
us-made solid pine cabinets and handmade
speakers just like the old fender amps
from the golden era of american
craftsmanship in tone all here in a tiny
little shop
in the mountains
on western north carolina wait a minute
i think i got one of these from this guy
i know this guy
yeah headstrong i have a [ __ ] amp and
i still stink but oh i sound great when
i stink
um
21-3
at halftime by the way
american-made
vibrator company
okay here we go i mean you know it takes
all kinds everybody's got this there's
plenty of voids to be filled here in
america dear billy ginger balls burr
re-manufacturing
in
usa what does rhee stand for is that
replying
i have no idea okay i'm an engineer at
the cleveland vibrator company in
cleveland ohio i love my job because i
design and test vibrators every day
i enjoy it but it's hard work get it
sometimes i'm sore at the end of the day
and need a stiff one
get your mind out of the gutter it's not
that kind of vibrator that's what i
thought uh we make industrial vibrators
for transportation and processing of
bulk materials ranging from animal feed
to iron ore cement to plastic pellets
fasteners to fun dip
well what does the vibrator do it shakes
everything inside the thing so it
settles and you can put more in the in
the container i don't even know what you
do here think of that show how it's made
one out of three segments will have a
vibrator in it as part of the production
process
yeah my wife loves telling people where
i work and says that i'm a professional
vibrator tester she's not wrong i wear
shirts and hats with our company logo
out and about and we have a lot of fun
with reactions
um
hate the show never listening again
can't wait to see you in cleveland april
23rd go [ __ ] yourself
i don't even know what i don't know what
that is let me just i'm gonna look that
up cleveland vibrator company
you know jesus
i can't do that next to carl fist's name
i got to delete him first here
cleveland
come on you [ __ ] [ __ ]
vibrator
company
let's see images
cleveland vibrator company
all right i have no idea what it does
it vibrates something but not your
clitoris
your clitoris
all right well that's awesome all right
said the wrong thing
all right hi mr burr
i'm a big fan of your comedy and you're
acting thank you i was out for dinner
with my girlfriend and she invited her
friend who i've never met she was nice
and everything
was going well but i might have [ __ ]
up at some point in the night she
mentions
that she is now demisexual and explains
thank you that you're going to explain
this that it means that she only has sex
with people she has a real
connection with
well there you go i said so i guess
you're
i guess you're just not a [ __ ] anymore
[Music]
he said i just went quiet and she seemed
offended was i wrong
comedically no
comedically that was [ __ ] hilarious
um
[Music]
then on the date i don't know i mean if
you were trying to see if she had a
sense of humor
i have to be honest with you my wife if
i said that to her on a first date she
would have laughed
i think i don't know it all depends
because this is the thing
she might have been a [ __ ]
before or what society calls a [ __ ] and
uh she might have figured out the
reasons that she was doing it was she
had issues about something and now
you know she wants to turn over this new
leaf so she's trying to be this new
thing
and you kind of [ __ ] all over it so um
i don't know i got to be i mean i got to
give you props it's a bold statement to
make on a first date
um but you know you might have heard her
feelings but she also saw the kind of
sense of humor you had so
as far as in the realm of how much you
could have heard her what if he didn't
make that joke
and then she dated you and fell in love
with you and then she found out you were
this level of an [ __ ]
you would have heard her much more so
yeah you
i mean how did you know she wasn't gonna
like the joke but at the end of the day
in a lot of ways she sort of ripped the
band-aid off if she just immediately saw
what an [ __ ] you were now here's the
thing if you guys are going out again i
would definitely apologize
and just be like uh you know i shouldn't
have said that [ __ ] i was just making a
joke
but just to let you know that's how i
joke
by the way what is the purpose of knee
pads in football anymore
the guy's pants are always like yanked
up above their [ __ ] knees
and then they have the knee pad like
sitting where their thigh is
um why wouldn't you have it on your knee
that's a knee pad
um all right
well there we go so i got columbus
tonight tomorrow i'm going to be in
chicago my kind of town chicago is
traffic 24 7
chicago is
a [ __ ] beautiful city this time of
year
no more cold wind blowing off lake
michigan
i'm excited to be there and i'm very
excited
for my great friend joe bartnick i think
he's absolutely going to kill it
and knowing that he's absolutely going
to kill it and then start
headlining around the [ __ ] country
i know i'm gonna lose him as an opener
but
the upside
is uh
you know he'll be headlining which is
what i want and then also
i get to try out some new peoples
to new people see
this is what happens to all my openers
they all eventually end up headlining
because i don't bring cupcakes out on
the road that's just how it is i go out
on the road and i bring people that i
believe in and i believe in joe bartnick
and that's why i'm doing the 10 minutes
in front of his show
[Music]
tomorrow night at the den so come on out
i don't know if there's any tickets left
you can check
it's a small
you know
3 400 seat or whatever but it's going to
be an absolute [ __ ] blast and i'm so
proud of them that's it okay that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and i will check in on you
on thursday